le tournage de la belle et la bête a été
une vraie tragédie parce que il a failli
mourir pendant le film là une maladie
très grave et les médecins m'ont
téléphoné en me disant que tina
interrompez pas le film immédiatement
que de risquer la mort en 48 heures et
on l'a mis à l'hôpital pasteur
une cage de verre en trois semaines il
après le film après et le courage de cet
homme et des fantastiques a le moindre
aux projecteurs lui faisait mal et il
travaille avec un chapeau qu'elle
l'avait mis un papier noir de
photographes attachés avec des épingles
à linge avec deux trous pour les yeux
pour ne pas souffrir le site projecteurs
ils pouvaient plus se raser
il avait donc là bas qui lui poussait et
malgré cette souffrance henry de toutes
les secondes qu'il avait il donné
l'atmosphère sur le plateau de
gentillesse de de drôlerie il disait
toujours des mots drôles pour mettre
tous les techniciens tous les acteurs
dans la bonne humeur et à moi elle me
disait tu vois je te couvre de poils et
pour me punir le bon dieu me rends la
pareille
je suis moi-même couvert le poil il
était vraiment d'une délicatesse et
d'une politesse un travail incroyable